- academic held in the United Arab
Emirates for six months on spying
charges has lodged a legal complaint
against the Foreign Office
Matthew hedges says the FCO failed in
its duty of care to negotiate his
release and help him clear his name he
is demanding that an independent inquiry
be held into the case well Matthew
hedges and his wife Daniela
joining us now hello to you both thanks
for joining us on the program this
afternoon we appreciate it
Matthew to you first of all you feel
that the Foreign Office is not doing
enough what more could they do so first
of all it's not just to look at what
they can do now going forward but also
going back looking through their
experience and how they handled my case
for the six seven months I was in
detention its to say right where did
things what why did things happen in the
way they did what lessons can they can
they learn from to not only understand
why my detention happened the way it did
but also use that to help improve their
own service and improve their own
relations going forward for other people
so they don't have to go through the
same episode as what I did are you
holding the foreign secretary the
president for insectary personally
responsible I mean he would say that he
has personally intervened to ensure
Matthew's release no I think there's
been a big misunderstanding we both
acknowledge the importance of his
intervention in securing Matt's release
and it's something that were incredibly
grateful for
however the foreign secretary alone is
not the Foreign Office it took the
Foreign Office seven months out of which
six months I was constantly battling for
them to take action and another month
where I was holding an incredibly
extensive media and public campaign for
the British Foreign Office to act and
they didn't until the sixth month so
what we're trying to enquire and where
we're trying to understand is why did it
take so long and why did
everything happened so slowly these were
six months that were taken away from our
lives in six months where Matt was held
in incredibly unacceptable conditions
and that's what we're trying to
understand why why do you think it is
Matthew this is something that so far
we've had no answer from this is
something that no one can actually
explain properly why why things occurred
in the way they did you know I I was
sentenced to life imprisonment accused
of being an mi6 agent it's not only my
my dignity my my integrity as being
questioned by the decision taken by the
UA to do this but also questions that of
the UK Foreign Office as they were
implicated in that decision and so we
want to urge the afore annoy fest to
help us clear my name and show to these
types of countries to these
authoritarian States that you can't act
in this way and and expect to expect to
get away with her we ultimately are
looking for justice and a true sense of
accountability for those who kept maps
in the conditions they did and also for
those who didn't act in a timely manner
to actually be held accountable for the
suffering that we had to endure
throughout nearly one year and who are
those people who didn't act in a timely
manner well we don't know and that's
what we need to understand we need to
understand what steps in the whole
process of the Foreign Office handling
case went wrong and ultimately who are
the people and for the the entities
responsible for for thanks going as
slowly and as badly as they did no man
should be held in solitary confinement
for six months let alone being handed a
life in prison sentence were a crime he
didn't commit and
definitely people must be held
accountable and institutions must be
held accountable for this happening and
so Kate sorry to interrupt so we have
assisted the Foreign Office with a
general investigation to how they handle
consular affairs around the world but we
were promised and we have we are trying
to continue to urge the Foreign Office
and the Foreign Secretary actually who
made the promise to have an independent
open investigation to how they handled
my case until we actually get this
information and there has been a
thorough analysis of what actually
happened then we don't know where that
where mistakes were made and so
improvements can be made for the future
so other people don't experience what I
did mistakes were made
Danny we don't know and that's what we
need to understand we've submitted a
Freedom of Information request to the
Foreign Office it's been five months
since we submitted it and we still don't
actually have the documentation so until
we don't actually have this information
that we've urged the Foreign Office to
provide us to help us with we can't
actually assess you know where mistakes
were made and who made them that's why
it's so important so vital for the
Foreign Office to cooperate with us in
the same way that we have tried to
cooperate with them in improving their
own costs so the basis of your case
Matthew is that it took a long time to
get you out I mean what more is I mean
you you you admitted that it was an
authoritarian state that was holding you
I suppose the foreign section in the
Foreign Office would say diplomacy takes
time we need to do that behind the
scenes especially with a country like
the UAE and these things these
negotiations do take time but we did
manage to get you out as quickly as we
possibly could and while we were doing
that we had three or four separate
visits where we came to make sure that
you were okay that they are totally
valid points and I would certainly
understand that argument more towards a
country say like Iran but with the UA
who is a
an increasingly close ally to the UK it
it seems odd that it wasn't communicated
and the Foreign Office claims many times
in conversations to us that they weren't
they weren't aware of the actual charges
being held against me I was being held
in Sochi prolong such a confinement over
six months I was being fed an
increasingly strong cocktail of
medication I was denied even even
something as simple as a shower I was
issued with threats of torture and there
are there are many opportunities and
instances where in the Foreign Office
should have and I don't know where and
where it broke down but there should
have been more contact to to understand
why I was being held in the
extrajudicial way I was I was not being
held in a jail I was being held in an
office where I was protected and I
wasn't able to have any interaction with
anyone the fact that I wasn't able to
visit I wasn't able to have a visit from
someone from the consular section until
seven weeks into my detention after
which I had already confessed being an
mi6 agent under duress under threat of
torture under you know that the the
influence of the medication they were
giving me why why wasn't I able to have
an interaction with my government before
then if the the Foreign Office knew from
the from the very day I was detained why
couldn't they have used those close
links and ties to communicate to the UA
that I was in fact innocent no matter
what they believed it's your case not
against the UAE rather than the British
government no we're not we have to make
it clear that this is not about us
filing a case against the Foreign Office
this is about us and asking we're really
demanding what is rightfully what what
we actually have a right to is
information and clarity about what
happened and where things went wrong
naturally the UAE are the ones in the
wrong to have detained Matt but that's
not to say that the British government
had
no responsibility in in defending him
and actually stepping up for him seeing
as he was accused of working for the
British intelligence falsely what a part
of our complaint as well isn't that what
they did and some might say in you know
if you look at somebody like Nazneen
cigar ear active how long she's been in
jail Matthew came out within seven
months seven months of hell
without question are being fed this
cocktail of drugs and treated
appallingly but in the great scheme of
things that was quite a short period
compared to some other people who are
being held against their will British
citizens around the world and the
Foreign Office would say that that was
down to their their diplomacy with all
due respect and this is me being the
person who was in constant touch with
the Foreign Office for six months before
I broke the news public for six months
there was absolutely no movement Matt
had access to two consular visits he was
still held in absolutely abhorrent
conditions and like he said unlike
Nazanin he wasn't being held in a cut in
a country whose relationship to the UK
is hostile he was held in a country who
has a very close ally to the UK so it's
completely whilst your point is
perfectly valid and yes Matt came out
before many other British citizens have
been able to that's not to say it was
right and I think the only person who
can actually testify the hardship of
spending six months in solitary
confinement and being drugged is Matt so
neither you nor I nor anyone else can be
in a position to say well it was six
months so you're better off it's not the
case I'm not sure that I'm completely
saying that what I'm saying is that the
Foreign Office potentially they would
say was working behind the scenes
throughout which is why they managed to
reduce the length of time from a life
sentence to seven months in jail before
you essentially managed to come home
Matthew do you do you give them any
credit for that well they haven't been
they haven't assisted getting the
decision overturn
whilst I was held in seven months I was
given a presidential pardon the the
courts still sentenced me to life the
Foreign Office many intervened once it'd
been made public and they had actually
tried to stop it they deliberately tried
to stop the NGO in public you know when
Danny did go to the press they they
intervened to continue that that quiet
diplomacy route which you spoke about
unlucky but not everyone should have to
be given a life sentence I was taken
back to the same office I wasn't taken
to jail it was a completely arbitrary
process which occurred and the Foreign
Office knew that this was that this was
happening if they want to keep a closer
relationship you know with the UA in
this example or others that may be
holding people in such a similar and an
unlawful way and they should really be
standing up and highlighting their
innocence they've they've come out and
said that I wasn't in mi6 that they've
made that very publicly and they've made
it very clear so then we're asking them
to help us say this communicate this
wider to the to the UA to get the
decision overturned to make a point to
make a statement to say you can't do
this and you can't expect to get away
with it so other people can't be treated
in the same way in the future you think
that the Foreign Office Tony's began
working on this case once she went
public no what I do believe though is
that they case was escalated and their
approach to it was much more assertive
and much more effective as I did go to
the public I am perfectly aware that
there was a consular team who was
dedicated to working towards providing
certain rights for Matt but their
approach was not effective and our
question and our inquiry is why wasn't
it timely and effectively done